this is what I hate about a casserole no  matter how many people stick their foods  and sporks in it and no matter how eaten  it is it looks the same that is  disgusting dude potato salad tuna salad  egg salad macaroni salad pasta salad  coleslaw dog what are you even thinking  or all I hear is  germs  sickness all those things you're dealing  with expound  let them let them stay out too long and  what happens well what kind of animals  leaving them out everyone  yeah everyone no one properly takes care  of a salad it's kind of shelf life it  does it's got a quick shelf life that's  got a very quick show those good things  do no it's not it's a hot strip most  Pleasures stripper it's heading right to  disaster and you know that